good afternoon my name is Jamie Guidry
oven and I am a scientific program
manager in the office of cancer genomics
at the National cancerous today
institute excuse me today I'll be
talking to you about targeting better
treatments for childhood cancers and our
pediatric childhood cancer genomics
initiative the target program I have no
disclosure information so this here is a
chart that you can see is the US
childhood mortality trends for lymphoma
and leukemia versus all-weather cancer
sites combined it was from jco published
in 2010 and one of the co-directors of
the target initiative had published this
it's a colleague of ours and sita and
this is indicating that since 1975 for
about 30 years or so trends in childhood
cancer mortality rates were diminishing
greatly and this was more pronounced for
leukemia and lymphomas however this is
true of all childhood cancers what's
interesting to point out is that since
the early 2000s this trend has plateaued
and we see that treatments that we're
working and we're reducing mortality
rates are no longer turning in that
direction and things are fairly stagnant
so it's become obvious that there is a
need for new treatments in childhood
cancer across the board so the same
group that had published this data had
gotten together around that same time a
few years previous and noted that in
order to change the trend of childhood
cancer mortality that we needed some
more effective treatments this is
important for many reasons childhood
cancers are generally treated with adult
regimens that are those down or scaled
down in the dosage or in the timing to
account for a child's body and to be
able to handle that this is not always
the best option that these treatments
continue to be very toxic and so even
though children are surviving they are
maintaining long-term side effects and
morbidity that includes increasing the
risk for secondary cancers as well as
infertility continued pain and learning
disabilities and development and these
things need to be addressed as much as
the need to reach those who are not
surviving childhood cancers so the
hypothesis that led to the development
of the target initiative which stands
for therapeutically applicable research
to generate effective treatments was
that the genes or pathways that are
consistently altered in specific
childhood cancers are central to the
discovery of new therapeutic targets and
new treatments and secondly that these
insights will be one of the key drivers
of progress in identifying more
effective treatments for children with
cancer so a strategy for discovering
effective new treatments and children
with cancer is meant to begin with our
program which is a genomics discovery
program to find mutations that are
drivers that might also be targetable
with different drugs that are either
existing or could be developed now this
program is meant to go quickly through
the steps of preclinical evaluation
pediatric phase 1 trials and then to
positive defender for definitive
clinical trials that will translate to
clinical care so the target strategy was
to partner with the Children's Oncology
Group which is a cooperative group that
has a good system in place to obtain
clinical samples from their biology and
treatment trials they are possessing
rich clinical annotation so that outcome
measures can be determined there is an
emphasis on cases with high risk of
treatment failure as they saw earlier
standard risk kids or where kids with
cancer with standard risks are actually
faring fairly well on current treatments
however kids in the higher risk
treatment failures are succumbing to
disease we also wanted to aim for 100 to
200 cases per disease and that would
have to include tumor and matched normal
samples
we also decided that it would be good to
work in a collaborative network of team
science to more effectively get things
done so disease specialists are working
from within the co ji also with
colleagues at NCI to be able to
accomplish these goals and the project
teams will be analyzing comprehensive
characterization molecular results along
with counterparts at the National Cancer
Institute and of course NCI can play the
role of running sequencing contracts and
funding those to help further the
science and the type of sequencing that
was hypothesized could be done would be
not only targeted Sanger sequencing but
next-generation sequencing to include
whole genome whole exome and mrna seek
and most importantly is that the
characterization is sequencing data that
such a project which generate is made
available to the research community with
the clinical annotation so that further
studies can be done thereby leading to
more effective treatments in a more
timely fashion so a pilot was was
anticipated this is a map of what the
target pilot started out as I will be
telling you a little bit more about that
it began with acute lymphoblastic
leukemia and then moved into a pilot in
the neuroblastoma disease so as I said
the AOL pilot was the first one to be
tested with this new sequencing and
characterization initiative the goal of
that study was to characterize 189
patients they ended up being from a co
ji trial p99 06 this included high risk
precursor b-cell a ll patients who
relapsed within 36 months and also
excluded most recurrent translocations
with the exception of e2 a pbx one and
MLL are there was to be your rain based
characterization on these samples to
include gene expression and copy number
and next-generation sequencing that
included 20 whole genomes done with
aluminum and some with complete genomics
as well as ten transcriptomes in
addition to sanger sequencing that
included targeted resequencing of 125
genes and also some kind of sequencing
this study is complete and all data is
available at this time just to briefly
show you what I was bitter rating before
is that you can see here on the
left-hand side that newly diagnosed alo
has a good prognosis overall and most
children are recovering from the disease
however those kids that do happen to
relapse you can see have a very very
poor prognosis and a low chance of
survival with only twenty-four percent
as compared to more than ninety percent
and it's this group of cases that we
have chosen to focus on in the target
initiative so some major findings from
the ALL pilot with it BCR Abel one like
a ll that it is a phenotype that exists
with a gross deletions and mutations
this is all published it does have a
gene expression profile similar to
Philadelphia chromosome positive or BCR
Abel one positive ALL it comprises ten
to fifteen percent of childhood BLL the
incidence is higher in young adults high
frequency of icarus dilutional mutation
as I mentioned and an extraordinarily
poor outcome we have also found that
Jack mutations are prevalent with high
risk alo and that fifty percent of those
also have CRA left to alterations we
also have found recurrent mutations and
forkie pathways seem to be present and
pathways include b-cell development or
differentiation p53 RB tumor suppressor
pathway rests and willing and also Janus
kinases the BCR Abel one light cases
with somatic mutations and b-cell
development are extraordinarily
prevalent that about ninety six percent
however
Jack mutations and p53 RB mutations are
also prevalent in more than half of the
cases we have also found that there are
kinase activating lesions but no point
new patients and pcr able one like
b-cell a ll other tyrosine kinase gene
point mutations are rare a high
frequency of gene fusions targeting able
one and able to c SF 1 jak 2 pdgfr be
are also partnering enable one PDG RB
fusions highly respond to able tyrosine
kinases in vitro and xion graphs and
anecdotally and humans these are being
tested currently so some downstream
publications are listed here there have
been quite a few publications now to
come directly from the target project
team more about the CRA left mutations
in down syndrome patients specifically
as well as expression profiling and the
research community because this data is
made available to them have also been
publishing due to the positive results
of the alo project another disease
project was determined that to be added
as we had some funding so neuroblastoma
was the second disease chosen and you
can see here in this graph for the same
reasons that both low risk and
intermediate risk cancers in
neuroblastoma tend to fare very fairly
well there's a high event-free survival
whereas the high risk cases for whatever
reason really are not treatable on
current protocols so the high risk
includes stage four patients generally
between 18 months and five years the
neuro west west on my project sought to
characterize about 180 of these cases
with full characterization but there are
an additional four hundred twenty plus
cases with partial characterization in a
subset of those are low risk as
comparators
they too were using both array-based and
sequence based characterization to look
for driver mutations and they did gene
expression and copy number as well they
also had some targeted resequencing of
116 genes as well as the whole genome
and transcriptome sequencing seeing an
AOL but in addition they were able to
sequence 221 whole exomes to add for
information from the road this study too
is complete and all data is available it
was published earlier this year and the
genetic landscape of high-risk
neuroblastoma the findings really were
that there's a quite a low median exonic
mutation frequency and very few
recurrent gene mutations seeing in the
cases that were analyzed and here to the
right you can see circles plots that
depict the fact that there are very few
rearrangements hannah Norwest mo genes
with significant mutation frequency
included elk PGP an 1180 RX mckenna and
andres and that rare pathogenic germ
lines are enriched including again and
out check two pink one and barred one so
some translation of the target a ll
findings into clinical trials for acute
lymphoblastic leukemia include a co ji a
phase one trial on Janus kinase
inhibitor relax and roll x 10mm pardon
me in patients with CR left to inject
mutations and they're also a phase 3
trial that's just beginning studying the
efficacy of combination therapy and
trading young patients with high risk da
ola and also in neuroblastoma a co ji
phase 1 phase 2 trial of alkan hamburg
alcon hibbeler crizotinib has the first
publication on that has already come out
in may by yahoo massey and colleagues in
Lancet Oncology and you can find out
more information about these at clinical
trials gov
so based on these pilot findings the
american recovery reinvestment and
recovery act or ARA provided some
funding to actually expand the target
initiative into what it is currently
today so as you can see here this is a
schematic of how the current target
program works and this is based off of
again the successes that we had in the
pilots of alo and MBL so we are still
using disease expertise in team science
both within the project teams and with
NCI there is transcriptomic filing both
chip-based and/or sequencing of the
transcriptome mrna n/mi RNA there is
genomic characterization also chip-based
characterization of the genome and epi
genome and gene sequencing whole genome
and or exome sequencing and as you saw
there was a targeting sequencing in the
pilot that is available now all of this
is being performed on richly annotated
high-quality specimens our current
target initiative consists of five
disease project teams we have a disease
project in a ll disease project in AML
neuroblastoma osteosarcoma and kidney
tumors it's important to note that we
are still partnering heavily with the co
ji and both the buds of a bio pathology
center out of Nationwide Children's
Hospital and Columbus works closely with
us and the co ji group operations and
clog statistics and data centers out in
California provide much of the outcome
measures on the samples provided by the
pathology Center and now you can see
that the target collab collaborators map
has grown quite a bit our project teams
are spread out throughout the country
and in fact somewhat internationally at
this point but most of our cases do come
from co ji here within the United States
so to talk a little bit about the
current target initiative and the data
that will be coming out later this year
2013 and early 2014 this is the
neuroblastoma project that i was already
describing but the ARRA funds did
to expand a bit so using mostly the same
cohort of roughly 600 some patients we
were able to fully comprehensive fully
comprehensively characterized about 210
patients with neuroblastoma these again
were staged for patients enrolled in the
biology trials from co ji about ten
percent of those cases we were able to
get as 4s cases which start out
appearing to the high stage but then
spontaneously regress and then we also
have about five percent of these cases
that were relapsed cases where we have
trios which is not only a two more
normal sample but also the relapse
sample where we can get a more rich
outcome the project was expanded to
include not only the gene expression and
the copy number that was already
existing from the pilot but also to gain
methylation profiling on a subset of the
210 cases as well as a very rich amount
of next-generation sequencing that
includes whole genome and mrna sync on
three quarters of the cases involved and
up to thirty percent of those cases will
have whole genome whole exome and mrna
seek so it's going to be quite an
exciting data set we have another ALL
project it is the same project team as
the pilot however it is a brand new
cohort of patients so again focusing on
the high-risk BLL patients the group
actually selected cases that had come
from both standard risk and high risk
protocols but had relapsed within forty
eight months of diagnosis about 40 to 45
of those cases our trio's again that
have a relapse sample in addition to
tumor and normal this group will have a
gene expression copy number and
methylation through help a say on a
subset of cases for array-based
characterization all cases will have
full genome sequencing through complete
genomics a subset of these cases and
some with relapse will also have both
mrna seek and mi RNA seek and about ten
percent of
we'll have whole genome profiling as our
whole exome excuse me profiling as well
acute myeloid leukemia project is
similar to those two mentioned they are
comprehensively characterizing about 200
high-risk AML patients half of them are
trios with relapse samples they too will
have gene expression copy number and
methylation or ray based
characterization all cases will have
full genome sequencing through CGI all
cases for AML will have mRNA seek and mi
RNA seek and again ten percent will also
have whole exome and those are primarily
trios the AML group was also able to
find 30 cases of AML that failed
induction and we are going to be
characterizing them with whole genome
sequencing as well as RNA seek and micro
RNA seek of the diagnostic tumor of the
failed permission sample and a cultured
fibroblast as a normal control a kidneys
tumor project was able to be begun we
are funding allowed for high-risk wilms
to Mars to be studied this is a tumor
that is generally thought of as a very
treatable tumor however there are two
cases in which the patients do not fare
as well and that is if they are in a
plastic or favorable histology tumors
that end up relapsing and we don't know
why so thirty three percent of the cases
of the 120 cases that are going to be
studied in wilms tumor are anaplastic
and about two-thirds of those
unfavorable histology to have relapse
and five percent of those that have real
itched we will have the relapse sample
as it comparator as well again
array-based characterization does also
consist of gene expression coffee number
and methylation and next generation
sequencing about sixty-five percent of
these cases will have home genome
sequencing all cases will have mrna
seeking mi RNA seek and about
thirty-five percent will have whole
exomes
with some additional funding this group
was also able to characterize clear cell
sarcoma on the kidney and rhabdoid tumor
there's about a dozen cases of CCS k and
they will have both are a base to
next-generation sequencing primarily
whole genome and the ramp going to mers
there's about 40 will be characterized
comprehensively this is a very will be a
very interesting data set particularly
when that's made public because it is a
full sequencing data set for whole
genome mrna seek mi RNA seek methyl seek
and chip seek and we also will be
including some cell lines as well as
human embryonic stem cell lines and
finally our last of the five major
project teams as an osteosarcoma project
this group will be will be
characterizing about 95 high-risk
patients these are mostly CLG cases
however we do have some external
collaborators to add samples the
osteosarcoma as disease is
extraordinarily difficult to get the
quantity of DNA and RNA that's at a high
quality for these cases simply because
of the nature of the disease and how the
bone has to be processed when extracted
but it set so this will be also a very
rich data set that really has not been
done before there is a ray based
characterization of gene expression copy
number and methylation like the other
diseases this is the one group that is
actually doing a chip based
characterization for micro RNA and then
there will be a next generation
sequencing of whole genome and RNA sync
and all cases in osteo will have whole
exome so this is a summary of basically
what I have told you all already but you
can see how much information is out
there versus what is coming so you can
see that most of the groups have
completed the next generation sequencing
that they hope to have completed on
their samples and manuscripts
in process now there is quite a large
amount of whole genome sequencing which
is unique to the target program and
there is also a fair amount of exome
sequencing as a comparison and the
determinant for us of which was a
possibility was really based on the
amount of DNA that was able to be used
but each sample obtained as much
sequencing as was possible so that we
could get clear results that hopefully
can be turned into effective treatments
for these children and here is just a
little snippet of what's economies or
circles plants from whole genome
sequencing and you can see in a ll am l
and m vo we have some good primary tumor
versus relapse comparators and you can
see again as was pointed out previously
for neuroblastoma and the pilot that
there are relatively few genomic
rearrangements in most of these
childhood diseases with the exception of
osteosarcoma osteosarcoma is highly
rearranged genome and we like to call
that the angry genome but there is
certainly quite a lot to study there and
this data again will be available later
this year early in the spring of 2014 so
this is a list of the pilot project
convocations all of which have been
discussed previously but I wanted to
remind everyone that these are data sets
that are currently available to the
public and we would encourage
investigators to mine them and start to
put them into their own studies so we
can move toward more effective
treatments in order to do that data
access can be a bit tricky but it is
similar to what is needed for other
genome projects at the National Cancer
Institute including TCGA or the cancer
genome characterization initiative or
jiwa studies so here are some URLs just
to provide a base if you need the
information so it's important to note
what the data access policy for target
data is target aims to accelerate
process of discovering therapeutic
targets for which researchers can
develop effective new drugs and
treatments to ultimately improve outcome
for children with cancer the only way we
can do that is by getting multiple
investigators to look at the data and
work with it and provide greater insight
then then even we as a fairly large
collaborative network can do the data is
made broadly available however we do not
want to compromise the privacy of the
child research patients in any way so
great care is taken in accessing this
data and who can access it and for what
purposes patient privacy is of highest
priority to the veggie I and target
collaborators and the genomic data is
protected in to tears the open access
tear is available for any data that is
not possible to identify any patients
whereas the controlled access to air
contains broader demographic clinical
and genotypic information but again that
data will not ever directly contain
patient identifiers so the first level
as I mentioned is the open access here
it is publicly accessible to anyone you
would be unable to generate a data set
unique to any individual from that data
some examples include HIPAA
de-identified clinical data tissue
pathology data gene expression data
unless it's QX as it could be genotypic
so that level 1 day 2 is still protected
to more specific copy number alterations
in loss of heterozygosity DNA sequence
data of simple single amplicons and
tumor associated mutations the
controlled access here contains
everything you can get with the open
access here it is a broader demographic
the clinical and genotypic information
that is specific to an individual and
possibly identifiable is kept controlled
although all other clinical data is
available publicly in the open access
tier and data regardless being in the
controlled access to here are stripped
of direct patient identifiers I think
samples of this would include specific
demographic their clinical data as
previously mentioned genome-wide
genotypes for each case information
linking all secrets traces to an
individual whole genome exome or
transcriptome sequences for any
individual case now there are two ways
to access protected target data which
can get confusing so I've made sure to
include all pertinent URLs and try to
list up information that would be
helpful for investigators first and
foremost to obtain any control tier
target data you need to apply for
authorized access through dbgap and your
project needs to meet the following
target data use limitation these data
may be used for biomedical research by
qualified investigators that are
performing research projects that can
only be conducted using pediatric data
ie the research objectives cannot be
accomplished from using adults and that
have likely relevance to developing more
effective treatments diagnostic tests or
prognostic markers for childhood cancers
this data can be used for research
relevant to biology causes treatment and
link complications of treatment of
pediatric cancers applications proposing
methods software or other tool
development not be considered acceptable
use of the data now this last piece is
under revision at the NCI and going
forward patients will be concepted in a
different format so that hopefully we
can loosen this data use limitations
slightly but we will never loosen it to
a point that does not completely protect
the child participants this is the page
that you would go to to apply for dbf
authorized access and the struggle
instructions can be found within it's
about a two to four week process and
once once you gain approval then
instructions are sent so the data matrix
is the primary source of all target data
and I'm sorry I skipped through this
quickly but if you go to the target
landing page the URL has been provided
you can just quickly link straight to
the data matrix
which is a basically in tabular form and
outlines exactly what is available and
if if the data is not publicly available
at this time then the links have not yet
and put up on to the matrix so this is
version so that users can easily follow
which which time point they obtain their
data from for publication it might be a
little bit hard to see depending on your
screen but you can see that there is
something called DCC open versus DCC
controlled the DCC stands for the target
data coordinating Center it is where all
of the chip based data is housed and
most of the upper level sequencing data
if it's if we're able to make it open
access we do and and you can follow
those links to those but as I mentioned
previously anything that does need to be
controlled can be accessed through the
DCC controlled link and then you can
drill down to specific levels of data
that you need access to so one important
thing to note is the clinical data you
can always find that here under the
patient data there are different types
of files that would be available for
instance if you went to the clinical
file you're going to be taken to an ftp
directory and just as a note all of the
data that is how's that the DCC will be
found in an ftp directory that is set up
the same as this one is and you can it
is clearly labeled you can just go
through each piece and find what you
need very easily the second part of this
is a case matrix so here we have
provided in in a somewhat excel format
so that it's sortable by the user what
data is available by each case and what
will be coming when all of the data is
released somewhere in the spring of 2014
is a sample matrix that delves one level
deeper and so even by each sample with
in that case so as I mentioned
previously many of our samples will have
diagnostic tumor matched normal and a
relapse samples for that one case and
they may have different amounts of data
depending on how much DNA or RNA we were
able to obtain so that way users can
quickly identify subsets of patients
they may want to analyze so target level
our target data excuse me is provided in
four levels they are the level one which
is the raw or trace data level two is
processed or normalized data level three
is aggregated data which is that that is
segmented or interpreting things like
teen lists and level four is cumulative
data that's a summary analysis results
and this generally comes out following
publication here is just a little bit
more detailed list of the data levels
and what might be found for instance in
the level one you can find cell files or
identifies and even sequence traced
files the level 2 or process files are
the loss of heterozygosity calls probes
locus amplification or deletion in a
sample bam files are considered or level
2 data level 3 data segments and are
interpreted would include for sequencing
math or VCF files if they are verified
than they are open access if they are
not verified than they are still
controlled access also expression
profiling or determination of
amplification in a case and finally
level 4 would be discovery that genomic
regions are amplified in ten percent of
target cases and things of that nature
that are generally published in
ministers so as I pointed out before you
can go straight to the target data
matrix and that is the preferred way to
get out the data but the only data that
is not physically housed within
the NCI is target data coordinating
Center it are the BAM or trace files for
the sequencing and those our house with
NCBI either in the trace archives or SRA
the sequence read archive and it does
require the same DB gap authorized
access so that process can be done at
once for both however if you'd like to
find out what is available through sra
you can go to dbgap and search for
target you can either search for the
parent project or as you can see on the
right hand side is circled you can
search by some project we have all of
the target some projects listed out so
that you can determine what's your point
of interest if you if you start go to
the DBA page and you actually scroll
down the page they'll be a link to other
NCBI resources and one of those includes
sra directly or you could go straight to
sra through NCBI and if you look up
target or the the PHS accession numbers
for target you will come up with a list
of what is available by the right hand
side you can look for sources of RNA or
DNA you can also look for the type of
sequencing viet genome or exome and
determine what is available so at the
sequence read archive again it's our
current system for storing bands at NCBI
we will also have Bam's available
through CGHUB in the future the same way
they are for TCGA the SRA website itself
does provide information on the samples
anyone can access the information on the
samples however they cannot actually
access the data files without navigating
through the DB gap website and that's
where things do get confusing you will
need an espera download client for
downloading any actual sequence data
files and controlled access once you
have controlled access you will be able
to sign in the same way you did to
request
to your excess but you will go
specifically to the project and I'll
show you more about that in a minute
there is XML metadata available at sra
which is there's a parsed version at the
DCC and now that we have some studies if
you are interested in just a specific
subset of target data as I said before
you can go straight to that or you can
get all of the target data controlled
access importantly gives you access to
everything generated by all five target
disease project teams so again this was
just from the SRA website this is
public-facing just to show an example
you can pull up the neuroblastoma whole
exome sequencing specifically it does
tell you that that was done at the Broad
Institute you if you click on that link
you can go specifically into a single
run and see all of the information
surrounding that what sample was used
what submission it was in anything you
would need to know metadata wise and
just to get through the identifiers all
of these runs and experiments and other
metadata are stored in sra numbers that
could be difficult to interpret so here
it just provided you with a list of what
these accession numbers stand for so if
it gets confusing you know what that
means however as I mentioned you cannot
get Bam's without a special download
client you do need the approval through
the DB gap to get to the target data
this does need to be renewed every year
you can download and install a spare
client locally on your own computers and
if you navigate the DB gap website and
download appropriate files you currently
to a degree need to look up IDs but this
is being changed right now NCBI to try
to make the process a bit easier and our
target DCC person
are happy to provide detailed
instructions for how to access this
quickly to go over it I showed you the
login page earlier but if you want to go
through the dbgap interface so that you
can learn more about how the database
for genotypes and phenotypes works if
you come to their main page you will be
able to go to apply for control data
access and it will take you to where you
need to go previously to login and to
navigate here to my requests so my
requests is how we put in the request
for approval but when you're actually
going to download the data what you will
go to is my projects because approved
users already have this loaded up into
that tab it will look similar to this
and you'll be able to just click on the
target data and what you'll find is
something similar to this this is ncbi's
new run selector where you can actually
sort by the information that you'd like
to obtain so if you specifically want
this is an example again from
neuroblastoma which is PHS number four
six seven but you'll note that each of
our sub-projects has a different
three-digit number at the end and the
targets parent study is to 18 so if you
want to sort by specifically whole exome
sequencing that was done at the road you
can do that if you want to sort by males
you can do that sort by tumor samples or
normal samples and that way you can get
the data set that you're looking for
prior to actually downloading I can tell
you if you do not do that in advance
downloading this material if you try to
get everything that's within target it's
close to 3,000 data files and it will
take a lot of storage and about three
months to download and this you can see
a bit of a tree view that you can also
use to get at the data you want if you
do want everything is certainly can
um and and then you would just rather
than using the run selector to select a
subset of cases you can just go through
the tree view and and check everything
again you must have a spare up
downloaded and you can check on the data
manifest if you would like for what is
available again this is going to be
thousands of rows so it may not be the
most efficient but if you have a script
for a different way that you'd like to
parse you could use it on this Dana
manifest so in addition to target there
are two other current programs on
knowing and the office of cancer
genomics including as I mentioned before
another large-scale initiative similar
to TCGA but studying different cancers
as the cancer genome characterization
initiative as well as a more
translational program that pulls
together the data generated from these
large-scale projects and that is known
as the cancer target discovery and
development or CT t squared network and
just very briefly CGC I is a
multi-project initiative and there are
some completed projects that were
looking at medulloblastoma and naj
non-hodgkin lymphoma the publications
from those that i have listed initial
publications here there are other
publications that can be found at the
website listed on this page for more
information but all of that data is also
available you apply for it in the same
way that you apply for target data or
for that matter for TCGA data even
though it goes through cghub you still
do use the DBA process for ongoing
programs in CGC I right now are the HIV
positive to learn molecular
characterization program which is
studying lung cancer diffuse large
b-cell lymphoma and hpv-related cancers
in hiv-positive patients as well as the
burkitt lymphoma genome sequencing
project which is looking at birgit
lymphomas many of them from overseas in
Africa the cases are being characterized
follows with mrna sea of the tumor RNA
or DNA sequencing a whole genome or
exome of match to more normal DNA and
again verification of candidate
mutations is going to occur same as it
will with target and as i mentioned cg b
squared is meant to bring all of this
large-scale genomic data together and
rapidly translate it for the patient
benefit or precision medicine this is
surrounding high-throughput
identification and characterization of
potential targets for cancer therapy be
it jeans or pathways as well as
identification of small molecules that
modulate validated cancer targets found
through either the CPG square network
themselves or through these large-scale
genomics initiatives there's an emphasis
on interactions of centers so the CPP
squared network was piloted as five
center network that did publish their
results and the data was so successful
with the team science and with the
approach that the network has been
expanded to 13 centers and those centers
will focus on bioinformatics genome-wide
loss-of-function screening targeted
gain-of-function gene validations Mouse
based in vivo screening protein-protein
interactions and small molecule high put
three high-throughput screening share
the cg d squared network will share
validated candidates with the cancer
community allowing investigators to
contribute to the understanding of the
mechanisms of cancer and potentially
accelerate development of clinically
useful markers and therapeutics for
evidence-based treatments as is the goal
with all of our projects discussed here
today and as I mentioned the ARRA
funding allowed for the expansion of the
CTD squared project into what you have
here and each Center has different
disease expertise you can go to the URL
listed on the previous page to find out
more information and use this data so
with that I would like to acknowledge
our NCI staff in the ocg program office
dr. daniela Gerhard is our director and
I of course manage most of the pediatric
programs dr. Megan Stein is another
program manager on our office who is
managing the CGC I efforts cancer
therapy evaluation program dr. Malcolm
Smith is co-directing the target
initiative and certainly was key and its
inception our Oct communications team
doctors Shannon berman and Jessica
mosaic and of course our OC g data
coordinating Center team who handles all
of our data dr. Tanya Davidson and
senior bioinformatics engineers patty
gasso on and Leander hermida I thank you
all for your participation and I hope
that you will visit our site and use our
data and help us to come up with ways to
treat our patients and if you would like
to obtain continuing education credits
please follow the link on this page
thank you